You may think of glaciers as slow moving behemoths
grinding their way, centimeters at a time.
But some glaciers can suddenly shift gears,
flowing many meters per hour
before slowing down,
often for weeks or months.
And such surges appear to be on the rise.
A glacier is said to be “surging” when it flows
at least 10X faster than its usual pace,
Many surges are too slow
for the naked eye to perceive
but time-lapses of glaciers
reveal their movements.
Thousands of glaciers are perched
near human settlements.
And dozens of surges over the past few decades
have claimed lives.
Not only do surges pose a threat
to nearby settlements,
but they can block rivers,
create lakes that later unleash floods,
and threaten the flow of meltwater
that towns and farms downstream depend on.
Until recently, researchers believed
that a glacier’s physical characteristics
and properties of the local terrain
determined surge potential.
But now they believe another factor
plays a major role: thermal balance.
Pooling on the surface during the melt-season,
water can infiltrate a glacier through crevasses
and ultimately reach the base, warming,
lubricating, and finally releasing the ice.
Neighboring glaciers in western Tibet experienced
back-to-back surges in 2016, killing nine people.
Computer modeling suggested that increased
precipitation and warming boosted the amount
of meltwater by 50% before the surges.
With more water to seep through the cracks
and eat the ice away, the glacier tongues
finally became unmoored, resulting in the surges.
To stay out of trouble,
glaciers need to keep in balance.
Researchers have observed that glaciers
more easily maintain thermal balance in
Cold, dry climates--
where they can shed heat to the frigid air.
Warm, humid environments--
where they can discharge heat
in steady streams of meltwater
Models predict that glaciers that don’t meet
these conditions are more prone to surge.
Sure enough, surging glaciers hotspots
are in temperate-latitude mountains,
such as Karakoram, and at lower altitudes,
like Svalbard.
If thermal balance is an important trigger for surge
then climate change will have an impact.
Recent findings suggest that a warming world
may be boosting the number of surges in some regions.
In Karakoram, from 1990-2004,
2X the number of surges occurred
than in the previous 14 years.
Analysis of surges of the Lowell glacier from 1948-2009
showed the time between surges has shortened
from 20 years to 12 years.
Scientists hope that by continuing to track
and model surges, they can figure out
why glaciers move at such wildly different rates.
If their findings yield insights into
the dynamics behind surge,
perhaps they can better anticipate sea level changes,
and ultimately save lives.